times are changing, if you don't keep up with the times,
then you're gonna left behind.
What do you say it's worth paying us
for what you're getting?
Well worth it.
I became that old school guy,
where I was like, oh, I'm not gonna pay for marketing,
I don't need it, you know, I have enough work.
I realized that I needed a couple of days of fill in,
not until I got the marketing that I've seen
that it was well worth it, you know what I mean?
And I recommend it to everybody.
I've sent you people over and say, hey, you know,
trust me, this is a real deal.
And it's the same thing,
and I think that a lot of the people just get caught up
behind where it was just referrals,
and you know, they were okay with that,
but the referrals are now far and beyond now.
Like back then, let's say 10 years ago,
you needed somebody to help you with the pool,
they started calling family members,
that's not happening anymore,
they can just open their phone and everything is there, so.
Times are changing, if you don't keep up with the times,
then you're gonna left behind.
You know, I started feeling I was getting left behind.